one-hit-wonder man what's happenin
reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm John
Humphrey hi guys I'm PJ Campbell hey J
back Campbell from the PJ Campbell show
I went on his podcast go check it out
ask PJ two guests are with us today here
on this specific fun video podcast we
are doing hopefully you guys like what
we have to say words we're gonna talk
today one of our top of were tears
whatever video you requested was due and
put up on the youtubes and today comes
from a man named Michael B Omni one
media go check his YouTube channel out
he had an interesting topic for us to
dissect a little bit here I wish we had
notes for this but we don't need notes
no goddamn ready no ups we don't need no
stinkin notes where we have thoughts we
are very smart men as with very smart
opinions as long as we're honest that's
what counts
exactly I think Louie CK deserves a
second I think that lost is one of the
best series finales of all time
when's Red Sonja coming out guys last
Jedi was the best and worst Star Wars
movie ever made and we just lost most of
the damn it god damn sure have been
honest about honest things that people
honest Louie CK should take some more
time away and change as a human first I
am I'm sincere anyway the topic that
Michael B has for us is basically
talking about if a franchise has had a
quite a bit of a break if they should
come back with a sequel or if they
should reboot it altogether what our
general opinion is on that he was
referencing films like how they're
talking about maybe do it Austin Powers
4 or rush hour 4 as opposed to rebooting
it and my take on this is pretty simple
now I actually put some thought into it
case by case basis it it well kind of it
depends on how strongly us
ciated you are with the actors it's
primarily comes actually down to the
actors more than anything else is how
much do you associate the actors and
characters with that franchise or is it
something where you guys like with bond
we said all podcast about bond and what
and and whatnot but I think that with
something like say is I was saying the
Mission Impossible cannot continue
without Tom Cruise I'll say this if
Mission Impossible took a 15 to 20 year
break you can continue it without Tom
Cruise I wouldn't be like why isn't 80
year old Tom Cruise in the role [ __ ]
this movie I'd be like no you get
someone else some whatever actors
willing to do crazy stunts now if
[ __ ] throw I'm in there sure why not
if it had like a couple decades of a
break
but then there are movies like Austin
Powers and like no don't do an Austin
Powers reboot you would need Mike Myers
for that I'm not his kid's character too
like yeah I don't think characters well
yeah that's a case where I don't think
even like audition to play that I'd like
that he created that yeah yeah I mean
well he like up see Annie ever you uh
each one he was always a there's another
character he added to it so I think if
you were to just save the rush hour you
know that the TV show didn't patent did
you see the TV show yeah it was awful
and I'm a big bill Lawrence fan he
created scrubs and Spin City rush hour
did not work as a TV show this because
did they die nap
like the one that surprised me the
feedback I heard off this show that I
haven't seen it because I was so opposed
against it but people loved it was
lethal weapon yeah you know what intro
first I can actually say that cuz I was
one of the people who if you guys
they've known me long enough I was very
against the Lethal Weapon reboot because
for me Lethal Weapon was singularly
Danny Glover and Mel Gibson percent long
but the one thing I will say regardless
of what happened behind the scenes will
claim Crawford and Damon Wayans Jr or
Damon Wayans senior I should say right
yeah what you ever wanted is you see
yeah senior they were really good
together their chemistry was great and
they brought something to the roles that
I hadn't thought you could do outside of
yeah but at the same time lethal weapon
to me will still always predominantly be
the movies
and I feel like you might be able to get
away with it better if you reboot it in
a different format their medium you know
yeah well I think rush hour actually
could have succeeded as a TV show
because it's a different medium if they
were to do the movies much much more
harder to wrap your brain around well
and it's kind of interesting cuz you
bring up lethal weapon and that's one of
those movies that were continually
hearing that WB is really trying to
grind away at potentially doing a fifth
movie especially with Mel Gibson kind of
coming back in the light now as an actor
and a filmmaker Danny Glover's not doing
a whole lot outside of the badass movies
or whatever those are with Danny Trejo
like those guys aren't doing a ton and
nostalgia is all the rage right now and
that's really where this question needs
to is coming from is the idea of
nostalgia in the CES and so if you're
gonna do a Lethal Weapon movie you might
as well do it with them because if
you're doing the movie it has to be them
yeah especially for that series
nostalgia a lot comes to play into it if
you're gonna do a part 5 - well I feel
like for the longest time I've had a
Lethal Weapon 5 idea you have and you
just gotta start off where Murtagh is
retired it is - over this [ __ ] now and
something leads I feel like there's an
easy segue and a fun way to get back
into it but generally speaking it really
does come down to it really just does
come down to that and especially if it's
a duo type of thing yeah and I and I
feel like I don't know how do you feel
how do you personally feel about the
Ghostbusters reboot so personally when
it comes to the Ghostbusters reboot I
wasn't a fan of it not because I don't
think it's not that I don't like the
movie itself I actually like the movie
as its own thing the biggest problem is
is that when they came back with it if
you're gonna do a movie that is so
beloved that Ghostbusters you need to at
least acknowledge the world that it
happened it exists and I think that the
biggest problem and I especially in a
world where a force awakens exist in
Jurassic world exists we are coming back
to these worlds in a time where time has
passed but it's a familiar world you you
know the things that we know happen
still you don't necessarily have to have
the characters and I think the biggest
problem with Ghostbusters as a movie was
that by not acknowledging
gene the original events happen but then
you bring the other cast members back
like that yeah they're in your remake
became confused yes
we I think a lot appear at least my
experience was sitting there going wait
is this supposed to be connected or not
is writing Bill Murray's a different guy
I guess you meet her at all back strokes
and it's very confusing and because of
that that movie lost its own identity
because it didn't have an idea well yeah
I mean we I think we were all under the
pressure it's gonna be a soft reboot and
it wasn't a song right but it was a
straight-up remake and I think your
safest bet a lot of different actors are
too old is usually a soft reboot as your
safest bet but sometimes that might not
even work you're like I think I'm like
Independence Day - what when you like
soft reboot that hurt a lot now is that
a bad rule that was like real I I watch
it many years after he's like I don't
know two years many years like tears
every came out and I heard how terrible
it was and I watch that and I was like
that whole thing with like passing down
them like Ghostman a lot of people are
excited for this next Ghostbusters movie
right right and I'm like I'm not I don't
hey I'm not looking for the fandom yes -
it'd be like whoa we know it's gonna be
anything we need a real trailer first -
no is this another pass in the man'll
thing cuz that's what it sounds like to
me and that usually doesn't pan out
pretty well well it's this is the hard
part is I feel like whenever you
approach one of these kinds of things
it's been a while we got to make another
I think the first question you need to
ask yourself is do people love the
concept of what this is or the people
involved in how much do those two things
rely upon or intertwine with each other
I know I've harped on Point Break a
million times but Point Break was coming
out as a remake and I was like nobody
loves Point Break because of what the
plot is it's about it's about Keanu
Reeves and it's about Patrick Swayze and
Gary Busey and Lori petti it's about
that and so yeah I feel like you starts
like ghostbusters to me I feel like you
could reboot a million times and it's
fine because that is we love those
characters but the concept itself is
such a lucid thing
it doesn't have to be those characters
and I feel like the mistake they made
with the Ghostbusters reboot is like I
thought after so much time you do
something new yeah don't weigh yourself
down necessarily with being beholden to
the old movie unless you're going to
commit to that that's a that's a great
point actually about whole concept
versus characters like I think that's
why Lethal Weapon a rush hour I could
fathom least even get away with it
because there are concepts or why that's
harder for me to see them getting away
with it
because their concepts are not exactly
original what made those guys worry [ __ ]
buddy comedies but yeah
yeah that's true and and that's why yeah
that's actually a great plats of best
way to put it is this really comes down
to is it what made it work was it the
concept Plus characters or was it only
the actors involved characters and that
it's interesting because then you look
at something like die hard where the
concept is great and we like Bruce
Willis but it didn't stop die hard 5
from being really really awful and now
they're talking about that die hard year
1 prequel which I don't want all equal
movie but I don't think die hard is a
franchise necessarily needs to end with
that and I think you could do it without
Willis someone like Paul Rudd who's like
an everyday kind of guy who ends up in
the same situation and kind of updating
it for now might actually work if just
depends on the person you're putting
into it because clearly if Bruce Willis
doesn't give a [ __ ] about die hard at
this point it should go to someone who
does but do you think I like to me I
thought that die hard franchise should
stop it's not going yeah and you can
also make the same application to
something like alien at this point alien
is now had the prequel series that
clearly has not worked for people on any
sort of level I mean I'm a like
Prometheus and covenant for different
reasons but as a whole audiences didn't
react we can see people were at least
very interested in prometheus sure like
Prometheus was it was a box-office hit
because of the fact that you know like
we all heard that was an alien yeah and
that's what that comes back to like
there's no Ellen Ripley but no one
complained about that it was all about
the world and the exploration of that
works like guys moving something didn't
deliver on that but what we wanted as
audiences was enough to sell us on
seeing that movie but but it would be a
different story if they were doing alien
5 Ellen Ripley isn't it but I saw
Sigourney Weaver right now with alien as
a franchise may be the worst idea would
be to go back to alien and kind of do
what Halloween did where I kinda blob
cancer directed yeah right and then you
get someone to be newt and she can take
over the franchise weird Wow and then
cross that [ __ ] all over and then James
Cameron revives those hopes a week ago
yeah wait which new set of home Oh which
hopes is he getting up of mine now if
you didn't hear he is talking to
Blomkamp about trying to bring it back
alien yeah oh yeah he was talking about
it on the Alita red carpets birthday
Scott seems like a controlling boyfriend
over the Alien franchise might as much
everyone forgot that I came up with this
and now I'm gonna just make so many so
everyone associate you and me my avatar
well look Ridley let it go
just let it go let me think of all of us
please let it go is let it go but I will
say it is depending on what we've been
talking about and you look at Blade
Runner Blade Runner tube later on 2049
is one of those things where maybe not a
lot of people were asking for a Blade
Runner sequel but they made a movie that
worked for a new audience as well as
fans and it's really it's not a easy
thing to kind of get on that line and
they made it work I feel like for a
sequel soft reboot that Blade Runner
2049 was I feel like I wish it was a
bigger hit me too yeah because they
yeah I love like they [ __ ] it I
forgot Harrison force was show up and
that's how good it was and I was like oh
yeah I forgot about Harrison for being
in this until we saw the familiar planet
from the trailers and I was like oh [ __ ]
yeah that's right Harrison Ford show
some beautiful synthesis when those
points work correctly because it's like
you have this world we're enticed by you
have this story this core story that
we're enticed by and you have Harrison
Ford who is kind of at least synonymous
with that movies one of the first things
that you think of and a couple other
actors as well and all those things come
to light in Blade Runner 2049 and that
is kind of a great example of how this
can work beautifully with all of those
elements yeah cuz you know Harrison Ford
is not the point he's not there for half
the movie but you know he's still really
compelling when he gets there and he's
integral and his storyline is very
important in tying the whole whereas
look at Indiana Jones it might be harder
to try to reboot Indiana Jones because
we're so tied to Harrison Ford as the
character right now see that's what I
find fascinating because when when there
was all that talk about Chris Pratt as I
was gonna bring him up earlier they're
talking about Chris Pratt possibly
taking over didn't really seem to be a
lot of hate for know which is which
surprised me because I'm like I feel
like you know anytime you talk about
replacing Harris before for anything
what the [ __ ] do you think you're doing
but for that specifically people see I
think I also think any Anna Jones can't
continue without Harrison Ford and I
don't know I bet that's a very unpopular
opinion well it's there's a world it's
adventure and there's not exactly a
depth of die you know well and I don't
think you're necessarily wrong we do
have to remember there was the TV show I
mean Sean Patrick Flanery is a
technically played the role many more
times than Harrison Ford actually did
and he was quite good in it and I
wouldn't mind seeing someone else take a
crack at it
but you also kind of like what we talked
about with bond you have to go back yet
to make a period well no yeah specials
anymore to go you wanna go to ease
modern Indiana Jones is just national
treasure
we have the movie Nicolas Cage was in it
and it was great
I would actually like to see a mod like
the great-great-grandson of Indiana you
[ __ ] cause Indiana Jones even though
it's such a defining character the thing
is if any of these any of these
franchises they all have the defining
characters in there
defining actors portraying those roles
the difference is the concept of world
big enough to explore that thing without
them you see like Han Solo prequel was a
weak like there's always this is such a
big great that's why I thought this
would be an interesting talk because
it's such a big gray area know what
answer yeah every variable matters for a
project because solo wasn't a
continuation it was a origin prequel
thing and that's that's a different
topic though because I'm like well the
thing that went wrong there is ain't no
one really wants to see the origin
explored of Han Solo here BD just thrown
out Reb we just saw on solo play I'm in
force awakens we don't want to see
another guy play him right now you know
definitely not doing his own thing with
trying to do here is important like that
that's a that's a completely different
type of conversation sorry Alden I feel
bad for them I do too I I mean that
legitimately cuz you know what all
things being equal when it came to solo
he's not the problem with it and I think
so I actually think solo might be
closest to what Lucas would have liked
Star Wars to become in a lot of ways and
so like a fan film that was really
expensive well it also felt like a film
that no one actually knew what they were
but I mean Alden at the end of the day
kind of got a bad deal I would like to
see him get to play the role again maybe
Disney Plus could think about it that
would be fine well unless I mean the
cardinal sin of that movie commits is
just being kind of middle-of-the-road
being kind of familiar in boiler plating
and I think a big a big part of the
issue with this is also the scripts and
that's a big conundrum to me as well
because coming back after so long I feel
like franchises could do maybe nowadays
depending on which franchise you are
with maybe being a little less beholden
to
nology and making sure that things need
to fit together it's like I feel like
you don't have to be episodic but
shallow you could be episodic and go you
know for broke on telling the story you
want to tell this time and then maybe we
could get used to the fact that they
don't have to just feed directly into
each other because part of what like
bringing up the idea of Austin Powers
for a rush hour for it's like I find
franchises interesting in that in that
both those cases I would say make a
sequel because time is now passed and
you get instant development from that
it's like every Evil Dead we come back
to ash he's a little older he's in a
different point that's like that and the
thing is if we don't work with that it
it works against the movie like that's
why I turned off dumb in number two I
rented Dumb and Dumber is one of my
favorite movies and favorite comedies
ever and then I rented Dumb and Dumber
to [ __ ] money at goddamn but I had to
like physically grab a copy and put it
in and I got like 40 minutes in and I
just turned it off I will say that
opening Jo is amazing in the movie
though that one in the trailer yeah okay
but I mean you're not wrong I'm not
disagreeing with it
I felt like that big thing with that is
they just tried making it they tried
making Jeff Daniels and Jim Carrey just
do what they did 20 years ago and they
didn't take advantage of trying to like
explore where they really liked now like
know the whole joke is they haven't
changed one bit you know and I for me
personally I felt like that was a big
hindrance towards if I'm like I'm paper
that sounds funny like oh they haven't
changed at all but you're staring at
them and they have it's interesting when
you look at Halloween which came out
last year where they that was one of the
big things is you cut out everything
else and what happens to Laurie forty
years later what does that mean to her
as a character where do you find her now
what did the events of that night do to
her and that's kind of why I'm looking
forward to the next Terminator movie
yeah is for that Sarah Connor element I
have no clue what they're doing with
Arnold that sounds so confusing what
they've been saying I don't even care at
this point I just kind of want to see it
don't think too hard about that time
stresses your mind
as a movie that's it's a several movies
line if you do any time-travel plot now
somebody says that and we don't have any
questions yeah that's the thing I'm
curious about the most what this is is
there even time travel involved with
Terminator and Terminator is another
example of what we've been talking about
where you're cutting out a lot of what
happened and you're doing a movie that's
so many years later and you're catching
up with Sarah Connor now and if Judgment
Day is technically never happened does
John Connor still become the savior of
humanity what does that do to those
characters yeah that's a very
interesting thing to kind of explore
well I've always thought I mean this is
a really big side tangent I've always
thought would be a kind of a cool John
Connor graphic novel to do if you dealt
with the idea that whoever the kid is
that Sarah Connor is pregnant with at
the end of Terminator 1 is probably not
the same John Connor who sent because it
makes no sense in timeframe wise how
because Kyle Reese was obviously born
after John Connor because he has this
whole thing of like yeah John Connor was
my mentor and then he goes back and
impregnated Sarah Connor so she just
named some kid John Connor and put all
this mental [ __ ] on him but that's not
the same John Connor we should make a
bet new comedy and like where this kid
is like I've been told I'm supposed to
be the savior of humanity but I just
like flip burgers on an alternate
timeline because this begs the question
of okay was there first time he got sent
back or did it always happen but yeah if
you did like never will but yeah you do
an alternate timeline where he just got
the bad genes and he's kind of
uncoordinated kind of a dweeb you know
he's he's thrust with this world Savior
who you know thing that could be really
fun fish out of water you know sky
dancer anyone over there wants to
contact us we would be willing to make
this into a sick [ __ ] you brighten up
determine your friend go comedy yeah my
comedy with I think I think time
allotted to has a big difference to dude
like I think with Genesis when that came
out honestly I wasn't when I
the trip it wasn't like [ __ ] this movie
I didn't feel that way when I saw that
trailer and I wasn't upset about the
recasting of Michael Biehn and Linda
Hamilton like that didn't upset me
I wasn't like I'm married to those
performances so heavily even though I
think Linda Hamilton is insanely
incredible interpreter one and
especially Terminator 2 I I wasn't upset
by it because so much time has passed
and it was a different kind this term
really lends itself to a world where you
can do that but but yeah I think time
has a lot to do it like to meet
ghostbusters of getting the original
guys back I'm like I feel like Bill
Murray is the only one you could
potentially be looking forward to but do
I really give a [ __ ] about Dan Aykroyd
and Ernie Hudson I do I really care
about that and you know that Bill Murray
doesn't care that much did you know Bill
Murray just doesn't give a [ __ ] about
anything anymore yeah dan Aykroyd is
kind of just this weird now he has
Christmas cold vodka yeah that's right
true and Ernie Hudson always got the
short end of the stick in those
Ghostbusters movie you see nothing is
always kind of push to the back
I still have hope for the new one
because I think that between ivan
reitman son coming in and having jason
reitman like kind of take his own crack
at something that he was so passionately
a part of as a kid and to try to
capitalize on that now is very
interesting and I don't necessarily mind
the idea of it kind of having a stranger
things vibe with the kids front and
center it's just all gonna be dependent
on how it's handled
yeah and that's kind of what we've been
talking about with this whole thing and
one thing I wanted to go back to you
real quick that you had brought up with
the serialization is we kind of saw with
Aquaman one of the things that DC tried
to do really with that film was do a
movie that went for broke it wasn't
necessarily tied to everything else that
was going on and DC's in a weird place
right now where Justice League was
financially a disaster a flicks out his
Batman cavils probably out of Superman
what do you do with those characters are
you gonna reboot them within this
timeline what are you gonna do now
and it's a tough place to be one Wonder
Woman was successful an alpha man was
successful and Shazam looks like it's
gonna be successful and you're making
another movie with Harley Quinn yeah and
so it doesn't really matter how much
time is passing at this point it just
becomes just tell me the story I don't
really care about the continuity all
universe buildings yeah I feel like
amazing spider-man destroyed the time we
should wait barrier yeah coming out like
four years later I'm something like that
like that there are no rules now in
terms of when you can do all this I do
yeah I'm curious as to what's gonna
happen to the DC you just because yeah
right now their foundation is such a
mess and certain key elements are gonna
stay the same and some are gonna change
and in like 15-20 years people are gonna
watch Man of Steel and start this
journey and get real confused okay let's
just talk for life three more minutes oh
I'm gonna quickly type in on here
upcoming sequels 2019 let's see what we
got here
Oh sequels remakes reboots prequels and
spin-offs
so many coming up Top Gun maverick you
see Top Gun maverick that makes that
makes perfect sense to me that you would
get Tom Cruise back because we all see
he's alive and kickin my you know what
he's business well I'm not just that the
idea of what would have happened to him
in a kind of a time when drone fighting
and stuff has come become popular what
does that do to someone like him yeah
someone who's literally his life
revolved around flying planes untitled
Indiana Jones Freya they were talking
about Indiana Jones [ __ ] for a long time
they're gonna keep talking like that bad
boys is a great example of what we're
talking about
you need Martin Lawrence and Will Smith
yep you can't you can't you know that
movie and Michael not LA's finest the
the cheap what is it spectrum show yeah
yeah really like men and black
international I think is a was a really
poor trailer I did not care I thought
that trailer was very lackluster
especially because I'm like you're not
introducing anything new to me when you
got a whole universe
and they're soft rebooting that because
it did show J&K on the painting there
and to me that's I feel like you can do
that without a Will Smith and Tommy Lee
Jones well you know that comes down to
the cast you get and the people involved
and they got a good cast for it on top
of it and that's something that has like
a source material that it was adapted
from too so you have that kind of
baseline to plug and play with I feel
like whereas if it had been a movie
first we might be a little more
conflicted but there's one nice just saw
that as you were scrolling is coming to
America too and that's one that worth
I'm really hesitant to get excited
because Eddie Murphy's career clearly
right now has not been the best and it
feels like he's going really hard trying
to do something that we all love but
comic sequels are notoriously hard to do
and was anyone really clamoring for
coming to America sequel thirty years
later I don't think anyone's know I
think that's the kind of thing you hear
and go what yeah and maybe now I'm
excited I had no idea there I went
Beverly Hills Cop for is that well the
thing is is like these nostalgia based
comedies always try to capture the scene
like comedies evolved so much and and
what we find funny and amusing at like
there's times where the the Judd Apatow
comedies were the thing and now we're
going into more john rowe based comedies
i noticed that people are really
gravitating more towards things like
game night or tag oh yeah things that
mix genres and have an actual you know
tight editor not just let's let them
[ __ ] improvise you know people got
tired of their two hour and 15-minute
comedy and it's funny because in the
eighties like coming to America was one
of those that kind of did do the there
is a little bit of an improv go special
to do the same thing but it still feels
like a tight edit yeah and then yeah it
feels like here's a line or two to
improv not like okay here's what this
whole sequence of scenes might be about
go yes
Rambo is another one because Rambo comes
out later this year last blood yes and
to know Stallone was still out there
we've seen him clearly doing action
movies and stuff lately it makes sense
to bring him back to do one more I think
it also a lot of this also comes out to
us with the character and actor
associated with it does Stallone so
associated with Rambo and
the whole thing where I think you can
reboot first blood actually because the
book is so different and it's so much
more in-depth and it was the original
cut of first blood was like three hours
long because they they took a lot from
the book of it just touch it
so I I feel like you because that was
more of like a war veteran movie it's a
tale that said that I made I guess crisp
eighties action movie you know that
wouldn't be a bad one to do an update on
to do it now
I think sigh first planet but I think
you're gonna continue Rambo I continue
the franchise because I also think a lot
has to do with our where are we at with
the might well what's audiences
association with the actors now sure
today like lethal weapon five sounds a
little bit weird to me cuz I'm like
those guys are like it's [ __ ] weird
you know like if he came back from Mad
Max like that's kind of like Mad Max is
great oh that's a great example has been
cast you can just pass it on the men no
one was complaining and they go kind of
mad but Stallone we've seen like
everyone doubted him with Rocky Balboa
and then when he did it you're like okay
never mind do it everyone that's the
thing with how we work with with like
what's the audience's association with
that actor today I feel like men in
black the reason we can move passes
because no one cares about Tommy Lee
Jones Will Smith we would have cared
about but bad boys is like no that's
different because we know that they can
still do that and it's very them like
that movie still works bad boys wanted
to still work because of Will Smith and
Martin Lawrence and you need that with a
third one like those movies work because
of them yeah like if we know they can
that I think that's after all this talk
I feel like I say it
if we know those actors can still do it
then you bring them back and I feel like
it's that simple really
if we know that are still capable of
doing it you bring them back if if we
know they're not then you yet go ahead
move on was like I want to want to see
Sean Connery play bond again and please
Bruce Willis don't come back as John
McClain I just don't care no no no it's
getting an expense
going of actors who should not return to
old roles that because that would be
spectacular you get a Sean Connery bond
in there you can get Mel Gibson in a six
I feel like you could get [ __ ]
Antonio Banderas the place or oh yeah
shooters Ora they should and maybe the
repute of Damascus or Koror it is
fastened down the man Oscar Isaac as the
bad guy yeah alright someone contact us
alright guys well what's your thoughts
on this did you
[Laughter]
sorry you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation please click that
notification bell and check us on
patreon
PJ Campbell go check out the PJ Campbell
show as soon as you can it's free to
listen to check out my episode over
there and last but not least Michael B
thank you so much for requesting this my
homie I love you so much you're so
lovely Michael I'm gonna write you up a
file you give me nothing they give me
the opposite of bio this conversation
was definitely worthwhile that's right
Michael we're not in denial of how much
you remind me of my friend Lyle oh
that's a great compliment when I call
you I don't get a phone dial thanks for
the request you're the best send another
one next month we'll do it with much
stay pledge to our patreon so we can get
these podcasts on you gotta help us up
or something I can't do it
I'm white I'm sorry I'm like - no I 30%
according to my DNA ancestry
Michael we love you thank you so much
you are eloquent individual and we love
you go check out his channel see you
guys